こんにちははじめ社長です鬼わけで今日は
八景島シーパラダイスに来ておりまーす
同列かあったんこの風景いやめちゃめちゃいい人もねそんな金でるっていうかはなんか
コツコツというぐらいなのでわりとその人混みて心配はなさそうですなんかいい感じ
ですよ平日なんですけど
早速行きましょうか
[音楽]
ブーバーいいなーいいなーあーめっちゃいい時に続いてやるかてぃいきたいとおもい
ます
予想
[音楽]
ううっすごいすぐ見れる
rene
購入だから奪った
普通の全部フィートか
水族館です
[音楽]
まつげた人があっ
覚えているのかの一例ちゃったんでしょうねへん波
ん
[音楽]
me
none がすごいなぁいいねぇいいねぇいい
津金なプランがキモツ
[音楽]
いいえ過ぎちゃ参加第2月には
興味絵じゃないってみたいと思います早速中へ入っていきましょう
[音楽]
そういますがすごい衣ステムっ
この間い味で
音楽が持った美術家もつけ本当だ
yeah ん
ni
んわわああ
ああああああ
ていました
yeah yeah
ええええええ
比嘉君なばいい
ぜひ持っている
あっはい陰力ねぇいい匂いする
俺わかんないけどそれでいい
ねすごい
n ame
これすごい俺に久美子氏けれども持った
いやーこれやってよ全然いつも通りですけどね
首てあげてくれるぞとれぱん
ああああああ
いるのがすごいなが違うみたいな感じがするんですよ
わからんだをはすごいねここ
yeah
おおぉ
精霊像まで語しゃべりローン
開幕までに沿う開くわーしょっトーン
青いですそう背負ってください
ベッツィ写真ですよどうすかめっちゃ
ああ
[音楽]
ん
ええええええ
写真が膨れるいいん
古いよそうかじゃあたらちゃったいいで d すねします引っ張らないん
というわけでこっからはいる箇所を見ていきたいとおもいます
だった行為を見てこのいる箇所歳三です
[音楽]
もう今迫っているとか組み立てないる箇所みたら見たーーー
見に来いにケット水しぶきがバーってくる感じやすいんで抜け楽しめるところ
でもべっさあ変わり最後にイルカショーを楽しんでいきまさぁ
シャンプーをしたままやんけ
えっ
忘れてさー
me
イルカショーの水しぶき難解でチャンプ洗い落とせるの詐欺で八景島シーパラダイス子
さんのいるが村に来てるんですけども
間違えてシャンプーつけたままでここに来てしまいました荒谷と2手段がありません誰
でもたよねーのはイルカショーのイルカががーんで出してくれる水しぶきだけなので皆
さんも下
違いでシャンプー洗い落とさずに入れ過疎言ってしまったときは参考にしてみて
ください
イルカショーもやっぱり床の駄文も快晴制限があるのでボスのシャープが荒い落ちるの
かユーザーさんがジャンプできなくなるのか結構あのおちりこ爪がきわどいところだと
思います泡立つ的には十分だと思うので早速イルカさんの2カ所
やってもらいたいと思います
[音楽]
なるほど
あっです
雨に配備します
欲しいところでで r
[音楽]
ああああああ
押す前だほうがいいですねー
ん
[音楽]
me
さといった意味だん
ん
[音楽]
あっちません
ブーブー lpj
ええええええ
はん
[音楽]
上田日でもだったよええ
全然合わ流れてなんねえ貫通車
4つ良かったてやる
1件目は見えてたんだけど
以下寝かせた体ながらスって誰良かったんだけど意外3段目が見えなくなっちゃって
いる日の水の子低温なく見れなかったけど強くなろうかなぁ
すまないと勉強になりましたね塗りがそう
何か見える死ぬ気では散布がを迫って